due settimane fa circa forse anche tre è
uscito questo video sul canale di
stefano dalla sua visuale per di mente
abbiamo vinto una bad wars è che io non
so come si gioca ormai tra un altro po
pro abbiamo vinto questa band wars tutti
giocano tranne me in una maniera
dell'agerola fatto quasi un caso tra
dall'inizio che ho fatto il culo ma
stefano si è trasformato in chuck norris
per la metà del video quindi buona
visione
a questo riguardo storico pezzo di mare
nostro amico quello là il truck pelle ma
che figata
i palazzi dove materiali difenderci in
brani ma leali un calo che vero potrebbe
saltare in base rossani a spaccarci la
base ok ancora non sono arrivati
perfetto altro 2h da sola come non da
solo
la corea ho fatto una fine così la nota
neanche così morto esser morto via cielo
treno che desideri compare il generatore
di della fornace progetto di fornace
dai kamikaze isolato spacca letto
appieno loro al terrore 11 vita tre dita
una di fumo non sono estranei mazzarri
due cantoni berna la vasca primate
niente di vita tutte e due ma secondo me
se corriamo li facciamo fuori subito
dall ambiente di vita
tornando ai uccisi tra grande disastro
ho chiamato il nostro chiaro spiega
stiamo il re maya registrano non posso
anche smettere di trattare giocatori
straordinarie ma ma si già lì su ogni
lato e gli elettori facendo spaccati
loro
[Applauso]
100 in parte privata ucciso ad uno che è
successo zio che è successo ha affermato
io c'era un amore disperato di e grecia
mentre sta partita e mai a teheran e si
è troppo bene non è vero
giuro che vincerò per te va bene una mia
vera destra esiste un grande perché mi
ha distrutto al letto a caso è scattato
solo dietro no ma quello dietro che ne
vado o non so questo faceva una
sopravvivono cazzo cazzo cazzo
porca vacca occhio gravissimo dovrò no
aiutami
ecco ti aiuta il natale e il caso strano
che ha preso mandiamo niente mi vede e
non lo so però sta tornando quindi di
stato non mi va di questo momento
possono inviato non indietreggia cosa vi
faccio perdere tutto e meglio sulle loro
non se l'aspetta la punta ma è lì ma non
mi ha visto
no guarda ma subito mi ha quasi problemi
di tutti per carità niente natura
esistono turno io sto attaccando è
numero l'attaccante perché la mano tiene
pili perché non viene il lettone
precorre giocattolo è stato eletto il
suo pezzo letto
riescono a fermare a nessuno che cosa
succeda l'associazione di culi ma vabbè
mica vecchia tac i caselli che resta
bonera la partita della vita
occhio che un grigio la discesa per i
tecnici sopra il testo è ovvio e qua
sopra grigio e sopra i testi stacco
lasciando sopra dove le aziende di prima
mano nessuno sul sito adesso statale
d'occhio ma santino ha fatto un pò
l'incremento è il mio vecchio prete
seguendo vedere chi sei protesta che tra
faccia aiuta noi faccio come faccio io
martinetti pronta e se gli altri 5 4 4 2
una decina i fatti sono artista ma
arriva a velocità si vede che la
velocità le prime
ok questo il bancomat a cui oramai
non so che dirti non è vero sa quale non
so non perde più basso potere della
potenza configurato drago lanciava in
quello di prima guadagnava vitale si
perdono tra come la partita più strana
che abbia mai fatto
e dietro scatto scatto scatto piani di
qui il 2010 fra te e alla tua mamma
fatevi che ha fatto cagare e di lingua
dietro con gli altri con dentro con
dietro spetta non ci riesco a tanto è
però bravo novità meriti di ce l'hai
fatto un miliardi e la partita della
villa il periodo di mediante la mia
morte molto piedi lega ogni eletto fifa
ai la partita finale a tre sistemi vuol
fare dai dai dai che la partita finale
dare la chiedilo a occhio che sono
invece tod's affabili diceva che potevi
pagata cani siano dell'attacco equamente
la vita antonella sul forte ponteranica
e bravissimo ancora molto bravo occhio
che dietro la quale c'è grande non si è
più volte su fonte si è gustata dopo la
vista di una mente uno contro uno ti
meriti questa partita tutta la vita
facendo con due facce di fino
all'ostacolo ci proviamo
difficile rimasti faccio imposta ma
ripeto peccato peccato via oggi a un
peccato perderla
[Musica]
no no è la traversa una base occhio
vigile si sta comprando delle lobby the
johnson che è arrivato unite shop
fondare devo andare a roma forme più
maturo
[Musica]
cesare sta esplodendo
o mio dio fantechi l'aifa pista partita
una 22 c'è ti rendi e la partita però 12
anni perché vico non morire mai
[Musica]
un modo
no
io